je voulais remettre juste un peu les
panneaux à l'air parce que samedi tu as
fait tes people tout à fait c'est donc
ton émission la seule et
[Musique]
oui c'est une constatation et donc tu as
dit que je critiquais la Star Ac ce qui
est absolument faux parce que j'ai
toujours dit que la star academ fallait
qu'elle revienne et j'ai dit la seule
chose que j'ai dit c'est que la Star Ac
comme je l'ai dit là ce sont des élèves
de The Voice qui dorment au château donc
pour moi les codes ne sont pas respectés
voilà et j'ai souhaité longue et longue
vie à Sarah avec de bonnes audiences et
ensuite tu as dit que tu m'avais invité
tu as dit ça donc tu peux les remettre
les trucs mais pas les passer les tweets
mais montre-les et ensuite tu as dit que
je ne pouvais pas venir que tu m'avais
invité que je pouvais pas venir si tu
étais un bon animateur tu discuterais
que ta production j'ai ma maman qui est
très malade et je vais être de mettre
près de ma mère voilà et donc ça m'a un
peu emmerder pour que je me carnet assez
proche
donc quand on sait pas on ferme sa
gueule ouh là ah ouais d'accord
c'est comme ça moi je suis franc du
colis au lieu de dire
tout le monde te dira que j'ai déjà tout
le monde
c'est nul c'est mauvais on s'ennuie un
like ah ça manque de gens Pascal bien
sûr
tout le monde te le dira on l'a dit
voilà
j'ose pas le faire parce que peut-être
comme je peux faire un tour le dimanche
en tout cas pour quelqu'un il avait dit
non non je vais y aller mollo
[Applaudissements]
tais-toi tu me dis pas tais-toi tu
racontes n'importe quoi n'importe quoi
tu dis pas tu te renseignes arrête-toi
qu'est-ce que tu nous emmerde pas débile
c'est une question j'y réponds pourquoi
ils sont Pascal tu es pas plus gros rôle
dans dans la Star Academy bah ça c'est
pas fait tout simplement pourquoi ça
c'est pas fait bah on a discuté avec
benjaminer mais c'est pas parce que tu
es tu es un peu avec nous
ça peut l'être à aidé après si ça a pas
idée après c'est leur choix moi ça
m'empêchera pas de rester là et d'être
très bien avec vous
5000 euros non mais pour toi toi
l'argent façon c'est un problème avec
toi la vie avec Mbappé et tout on n'aura
jamais le matin
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi demain toi demain
il faut arrêter de l'argent mais c'est
un gros montant mais non mais ça dépend
ce qu'on te propose ça dépend ce qu'on
te demande pas beaucoup si ça vaut pas
plus hein
bien sûr c'est beaucoup mais c'est pas
une question qui ne voulait pas c'est
question que j'avais pas le budget merci
Jean-Pascal en tout cas si tu veux venir
ici tu es le bienvenu parce que je te
sens bien agité
bien agité et c'est chaud